l es liens entre art bois et louis
pasteur sont très forts et aussi on voit
ça tout de suite avec clément janin
bonjour clément bonjour à tous
effectivement je me trouve au 83 rue de
courcelles arbois dans une maison
vraiment particulière celle de louis
pasteur ch avec sylvie morel vengeance
il est vite mon jour vous êtes la
directrice de l'établissement public la
terre de louis pasteur
ce qui est incroyable sylvie c'est qu'on
est dans cette maison et qu'on a
l'impression que louis pasteur né en
1895 quand louis pasteur vient de la
quitter
tout à fait on est vraiment dans une
maison qui a été incroyablement
conserver tout est authentique tout est
d'origine les meubles et tapis les
papiers peints et ça fait vraiment un
vrai morceau de patrimoine à important
pour la franche comté pour la france
alors dans cette petite maison une
ancienne tannerie qui était la maison de
ses parents louis pasteur ya passé
beaucoup de temps
il l'a rachetée à la mort de ses parents
il en a fait son lieu de villégiature
oui tout à fait et pasteur était très
attaché à arbois ir vs dans cette maison
chaque été pour les vacances c'était des
vacances quand même relativement
studieuse il invitait ses assistants de
laboratoire à venir travailler avec lui
à la campagne oui effectivement alors ce
qui est très étonnant qu'on visite cette
maison c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'on
n'est pas dans un quelque chose de très
ostentatoire c'est pas de la grosse
bourgeoisie c'est bourgeoisie de
province n'ont passeur il vient d'un
milieu modeste ses parents étaient
tanner il n'a pas oublié les journées de
son enfance ou au repas il y avait
surtout de la soupe de godet est pas
souvent de la viande
et puis après quand il est devenu un peu
plus célèbres certes il s'est offert
quelques éléments de confort un billard
un piano pour sa femme mais pour le
reste l'essentiel de ses économies il
les passait dans ses recherches
scientifiques et la dépense et surtout
pour acheter des objets de laboratoire
c'est difficile de conserver sa en état
faut prendre des précautions parce que
vous nous avez permis d'accéder à des
endroits qui sont d'habitude protéger
quand même oui alors oui bien sûr que
c'est un petit peu compliqué de
conserver la maison on demande aux
visiteurs de faire attention de pas
s'appuyer sur les murs de ne pas toucher
les objets il ya des guides aussi qu'ils
sont là un petit peu pour pour guider
les visiteurs mais il est clair que ces
lieux de patrimoine sont compliqués à
conserver qu'est ce que vous disent les
gens qui viennent ce sont des gens qui
viennent voir quels pasteur fils
le monde ils viennent les français
viennent voir l'inventeur du vaccin
contre la rage les étrangers viennent
voir l'inventeur de la pasteurisation un
chacun c'est pas chez tout le monde
passeur résonne un petit peu
différemment et il ya vraiment des
pèlerins qui viennent chez pasteur ça
peut être des médecins des vétérinaires
parce que passeur a beaucoup fait de
vaccins pour les animaux mais aussi des
cristallographe et puis il ya aussi des
gens comme vous et moi qui ont compris
quelque chose d'essentiel c'est que la
science c'est vraiment une activité
citoyenne et tout le monde peut en
parler à ce qui étonnant c'est qu'on
peut aussi venir juste si on veut être
plongé en un instant en 1895 quand on
franchit la porte et on y est là c'est
clair que là on s'aperçoit d' dévoila du
mode de vie que les gens avaient en 1895
19e n'est pas si proche de nous pas si
lointain non plus donc ça un siècle un
peu de transition avec un design qui est
très particulier qui plaît énormément
avec des objets 1 comme la lampe à gaz
qui voilà qui sont un petit peu étonnant
surtout aux jo coupe sylvie parce qu'on
va se retrouver à l'étagé on a
enregistré une deuxième partie que vous
allez pouvoir voir maintenant on se rend
à l'état juste au dessus c'est le
laboratoire de pasteur aux alliés voir
des choses vraiment fantastique c'est la
suite de la visite
et voilà on se retrouve donc au premier
étage de la maison pasteur sylvie morel
c'est simple si on veut voir le travail
de louis pasteur il ya que dans cette
maison qu'on peut voir ça il faut venir
ici arbois pasteur c'est quelqu'un
d'incarner c'est quelqu'un de
d'enraciner il a beaucoup travaillé sur
les fermentations des vins dans les
placards de ce laboratoire ou trouve
encore des restes d'expérience qui l'a
mené en 1878 sur sa vigne de montigny
les arsures on va encore tous les
produits chimiques qui l'a utilisé on
voit son microscope ses hôtes il faut
venir arbres ça plaît beaucoup aux gens
cette partie là le tourisme scientifique
entre guillemets il ya des gens qui
viennent pour ça vraiment oui parce
qu'il est rare le tourisme scientifique
en fait le patrimoine scientifique n'a
pas été digne d'intérêt pendant
longtemps et c'est assez récent et du
coup beaucoup de laboratoires de grands
chimistes grands savants ont disparu
celui-là ayant appartenu à pasteur
n'ayant jamais été utilisée par d'autres
a été conservée intacte
alors il se passe ici ce qu'on se disait
en bas c'est à dire qu'on a l'impression
que louis pasteur est mort hier et que
tout continue sans lui bonjour
nathalie vous êtes l'une des guides de
celui incroyable à vous nous avez ouvert
quelque chose qui est juste fantastique
ses marques et bouillon nouveau c'est
juste des expériences qui date de 1895
voilà du bouillon de poule ou du
bouillon de vaud effectivement avec le
fameux ballon inventé par louis pasteur
le ballon à col de cygne
alors ça c'est vraiment une expérience
qui qui fonctionnait qui fonctionnerait
encore aujourd'hui tout simplement parce
que ce bouillon qui a été stérilisés au
19e siècle est resté totalement
inaltérable alors que si vous voyez bien
au bout du bout du flacon il ya une
ouverture
voilà ça les gens s'adonnent trouvé ça
passionnant oui bah oui forcément
forcément est la seule explication
possible
eh bien c'était que les germes les
micro-organismes qui provenaient de
l'air ambiant ont été arrêtés dans la
courbure dans la courbure du ballon et
là en dessous on a des épisodes qui
contiennent d'autres choses et c'est
c'est sûr des c'est quoi c'est de la
peau d'animal s'essaie dans le dos le
oui et l'alcool ça oui un petit peu un
petit peu je voulais pas vous coller
alors on perd contre garder tout
simplement avec des étudiants de
regarder les voilà oui c'est du sang du
coeur des cobayes
ça va être spécial de dettes guide dans
cet univers-là vous périence incroyable
oui c'est vrai parce que aussi parce
qu'aussi on en apprend tous les jours
on en apprend tous les jours bon ben
voilà écoutez je pense qu'on vous a
donné envie de découvrir si ce n'est
déjà fait le travail incroyable de louis
pasteur on est au 83 rue de courcelles
ici à arbois la maison pasteur est
ouverte tous les jours et c'est un
voyage dans le temps
passionnant et bien c'est noté merci
beaucoup clément